you feel that your brain is actually
shrinking and you have brain atrophy
well as you age the brain potentially
could shrink by 0.4 percent every single
year and that can lead to all sorts of
cognitive deficiencies like a lack of
focus a lack of attention on something
you are a very a DD you can't complete
things without starting something else
over here your memory isn't that great
you can't concentrate and focus like you
used to and lot of that has to do with
just losing the amount of brain that you
have left so when your brain actually
shrinks you actually lose circulation
and you also lose your ability to use
glucose feel so you can't actually get
the fuel in the cell anymore so
Alzheimer's patients for example
Parkinson's their nerve cells cannot
absorb glucose that well so they
basically starve and they don't connect
anymore there's a lack of communication
so is it possible to grow back your
brain and how do you do it and yes it's
possible and here's how to do it there's
several things involved one is the B
vitamins your brain needs a lot of B
vitamins if you're deficient in vitamin
b1 for example one of the symptoms is
amnesia you start forgetting things so
that's very very important B 6 is very
necessary b12 very very important so
your brain is composed mostly of fat the
nerves are insulated with fat and now
you become deficient in B 1 and B 12 you
start to lose that fat myelin sheath
around the nerves also folic acid is
very very important you also need an
omega-3 fatty acid called DHA a good
percent of the fat in your brain is that
type of omega-3 fatty acid so how do you
get this fish fatty fish cod liver oil
and this is a really good product that I
recently started using myself cobb liver
this is not sardines this is actual Cobb
liver it tastes a little bit like tuna
but it's like pudding
it's like tuna pudding it's really
actually quite amazing I'll put a link
down below so you can order some of this
but you just need a little bit each day
to get your
daily amounts of DHA and you also need
phytonutrients fund of nutrients are
kind of giving you that protection
against environmental stress it's the
the toxic effect of foods poor diets so
all that oxidizes the tissue and creates
free radicals so if our nutrients can
help protect the damage from that
alright let's talk about blood sugars if
the blood sugar is too high or too low
or you have what's called insulin
resistance in which it'll be your blood
sugars would be kind of normal at first
but you have high insulin this is going
to create a massive problem with your
brain and this is probably the most
common problem right here I have tons of
videos on it I'm not going to get into
it right now I'll put a link down below
but blood sugar problems will cause
neuro degeneration and then you have the
stress component which if you're under
stress the high levels of cortisol can
also create a very similar effect and by
the way high levels of cortisol will
mess up your blood sugars okay so it's a
combination of cortisol directly
creating a problem and the insulin
creating the problem from the blood
sugars and of course not sleeping from
the stress can greatly affect the
function of your central nervous system
alright and of course you have the
smoking and the drinking will affect the
brain physiology too now if you're in a
situation where you don't have the full
capacity of brain function and you're
starting to lose your focus and
concentration you don't want to run the
majority of your brain on glucose
there's another of fuels that you can
run your brain on part of the brain
needs glucose but don't worry about that
because your body can make it its own
glucose from fat or protein in your diet
the thing about the brain is the brain
it doesn't have a storage sugar reserve
it doesn't have glycogen like your
muscles do so it depends on what's going
on in the blood so if there's not enough
sugar in the blood then it starts to
starve and that can come from what's
called insulin resistance and so despite
having a lot of sugar in the blood if
you have insulin resistance like in your
brain it won't work so you don't want to
run the majority of your brain on
glucose
you want to run it on ketones your brain
cells love ketones if you have any
question on what a ketone is watch the
video on ketones I put down below but
ketones are the byproduct of burning fat
and your brain cells will be much more
efficient energy wise running on ketones
and now last the most important thing is
the same called
intermittent fasting where you're not
eating so frequently and of course
you're going to do the combination of
both of these
but intamin fasting will increase this
compound in your brain called brain
derived neurotrophic factor B D and F
this is like miracle-gro
for the brain this will help regrow the
brain cells okay so you have to do a
combination of intamin fasting and
healthy ketosis to get your brain to
come back alright guys thanks for
watching I'll see you in the next video
so if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications daily
notifications that sounds weird well
I'll just remind you on a daily basis
how about that